how do we draw a graph of a function y
or f of X equals 2x plus 1
y is equal to X plus 1 is the function
how do we represent this on a graph we
can easily manage to draw its graph
provided we know what a coordinate plane
is it is simply a surface on which we
can plot points lines and curves it just
makes life easy as it has the X and the
y axis now how do we plot this function
is the question to plot it all we have
to do is try substituting a few values
in place of X and get different values
for Y what will be the value of y if say
x is 0 0 plus 1 is 1 when x is 0 Y is 1
this point will be 0 comma 1 what if X
is 1 if X is 1 then Y will be 2 so 1
comma 2 here if X is 2 then Y will be 3
2 comma 3 honestly even two points are
enough to draw the line of this equation
but let's also try out a few negative
values of X if X is minus 1 then Y will
be minus 1 plus 1 0 minus 1 comma 0 will
be this point and if X is minus 2 then Y
will be minus 1 if we join all these
points what we get is a straight line so
this is the graph of this particular
equation it is a straight line because
it is a linear equation its degree is 1
what if the degree isn't 1 let's see
plot the graph of the function y is
equal to G of X is x squared
try drawing it on the XY axis
what will be the value of y if X is zero
square of zero is zero and hence Y will
also be zero the point will be zero
comma zero if X is 1 then Y will be 1
squared which is also 1 so 1 comma 1 if
X is 2 then Y will be 2 squared which is
4 2 comma 4 it's interesting it's
definitely not a straight line what is
it what if X is minus 1 Y will be the
square of minus 1 which is 1 this will
be the point minus 1 comma 1 if X is
minus 2 then Y will be the square of
minus 2 which is 4 minus 2 comma 4 is
the point joining all these points we
get a curve and it's called the parabola
plotting and understanding graphs of
functions is fun and it's also very
important for your exam prep we will
look at more functions in the next few
sessions